join me now for reaction Republican
congressman Matt Gaetz and Andy Biggs so
looking at the latest polling data
Bernie Sanders is gaining momentum big
time he is for example neck and neck he
may win Iowa he's ahead substantially in
New Hampshire and what his fundraising
is really taking off while Elizabeth
Warren is tanking and all of a sudden
they're going to be forced back to
Washington in January off the campaign
trail with a Senate impeachment trial
perhaps Elizabeth Warren's decreases in
revenue correspond with her campaign not
wanting to pay her wealth tax but I
think that the Bernie Sanders ascension
in the polls is a sign that the
Venezuela wing of the Democratic Party
is showing a little life here and you
just got a wonder Greg who's gonna win
this thing on the Democratic primary
because you got Joe Biden just as the
the blundering gaffe machine that he is
you've got you know kind of the weekend
at Bernie Sanders campaign where he's
trudging along but but gaining momentum
and then Elizabeth Warren who I think
has had her ebbs and flows I don't see a
winner in the field yet you know
congressman Biggs Democrats are now
openly beginning to wonder about the
wisdom of Nancy Pelosi Adam shifts and
Jerry Nadler 'z impeachment farce that
that you know the numbers are indicating
this is going to backfire has they
created a political quicksand and now
they've stepped right into it
yeah they really have and I think Nancy
Pelosi's instincts were correct about a
year ago when she was kind of backing
off we don't want to really get going on
this thing but as matt said the
Venezuelan side of the Democrat Party in
Congress said look no we gotta have it
and she had to cut a deal to become
speaker because it was such a close race
she has taken the the bull by the horns
here and it looks like she's going to
get gored because of it
the reality is this has been a huge
mistake for the Democrats they have
nothing there are people within the
democratic conference itself that
realize that they have nothing and it's
done nothing but help president Trump
solidify his position with
you know people of reason throughout the
country congressmen those within the
Democratic Party you just referenced
them are they angry about what Pelosi
and Shivan Nadler have done I think some
of them are some of them who I've talked
to a quietly aside they want this to go
away
they wish it had never happened but but
you know what the Nancy Pelosi has got
him because she raises money for him but
the reality is many of them wish this
thing would go away and but it's not
gonna go away and she's it's actually
gonna blow up even more I'm afraid it's
a return it's not just that Nancy Pelosi
raises money for her caucus it's that
they used that money as a political
weapon against anyone who potentially
would vote against impeachment Andy and
I observed active threats on the House
floor that if the Blue Dog Democrats
didn't go along with the radical left of
the Democratic Party and support
impeachment that they would not be
supported by the d-triple-c so that's
the active threat we got the quid pro
quo I'll pull the rug out from under you
financially and in every other way yeah
the only quid pro quo I observed in this
impeachment process was the quid pro quo
where if the Democrats didn't line up
behind Nancy Pelosi as lemmings ready to
go off the cliff that they would then be
bludgeoned by their own party in
primaries well it may turn out to be
just the opposite congressman Biggs if
Nancy Pelosi thought that the mere word
impeachment and the vote that ensued
would damage the president politically
the opposite has happened here
I mentioned the poll numbers and now the
Gallup poll comes out and you know he's
tied with Obama is the most admired man
I mean talk about a severe bloomerang
yeah I don't think they could have
understood that that might happen to my
think I thought she knew at the
beginning but look that in my most
admired person poll there's a lot of
takeaways there and first of all it
means there's a lot of people who
approve of the job to president Trump's
doing as president but moreover there's
a lot of people who admire him
personally for trying to keep his
promises when he is in the swamp well he
said he's going to drain the swamp we've
seen and I think the whole world has
seen how hard the swamp will try to take
you back down and then I guess the other
thing is you can see how divided the
country
really is that Obama and President Trump
would be tied as the most admired men in
2019 is a remarkable statement that our
country is divided in so many ways but I
think it also gets to the point you just
made Gregg that and the Matt's been
making this point all along as well
this is boomeranging on them and it's
actually solidifying and lifting
president Trump up even more part of the
theory that Nancy Pelosi is hanging on
to these articles of impeachment not
transmitting them to the US Senate as
she wants to prolong this impeachment
notion as long as you possibly can't
hang it over his head but if it's not
working for and it's having the reverse
effect doesn't she wanna walk that over
run it over to the US Senate right now
and get it over with it's more like a
hot potato than something you would want
to hold on and hope that it would hatch
and I don't always agree with Mitch
McConnell but I think he made a valid
point that you don't gain much leverage
in threatening to withhold something
that the Senate does not want and as
Andy pointed out you've got a lot of
these members in districts that were won
by Donald Trump who will vote for
impeachment but who frankly wanted
through the legislative digestive system
as fast as possible because I mean if
you're one of those candidates on the
campaign trail heck if you're one of the
20 20 Democrats running for president
this has now become all-consuming the
election would be a referendum on
impeachment and right now it would be an
election that the president would
overwhelmingly win in the electoral
college by a fairly wide margin
congressman Biggs independents are
against removing the president via
impeachment and you just heard the clip
that we play from a CBS reporter Garrett
major Garrett who said you know any
president in terms of minority votes
would quote be happy to have this record
claimed so when you factor in
Independence the minority vote and the
president's rise in polling numbers plus
his tremendous increase in fundraising
is he I know it's early but is he
looking fairly solid
going into the 2020 election well with
everything there I like his chances
significantly but I don't think we
should rest on our laurels I think we
need to keep out there working I think
president Trump is a great candidate and
I think he's going to win big and I
think some of the things that you
mentioned the the response to the for
instance the black vote and and the
minority vote because they have the
lowest unemployment rates and those
demographics that you've ever had you've
had more jobs more people working more
people able to fulfill their life dreams
I mean Matt worked hard on getting the
first step back through and deserves a
lot of kudos for that the president and
and his team that has changed the very
nature of some of that stuff going on
and so President Trump has a a
significant approval rate right now
among black voters and that's incredible
and that's a great thing for him any big
Mack Matt Gaetz thank you both for being
with us good to see you thanks Greg